now
so so you're what you claim in your book
what
what is the reason for in your view what
is the reason for these owls
showing up in connection with ufos like
what is the
what is the connection between the owls
and these
tiny scientists in these ufo
saucers they so they might not be tiny
scientists in the saucers they might be
doing some other role but they're
their uh
the connection okay so
there's a term archetype which means
that
somehow within our like
plato originally is the archetype and
then the term archetype and then freud
excuse me then carl young
used the term archetype in more modern
research
and they both are implying that there's
a
um a
something in the human psyche in the
collective consciousness that we have an
embedded knowing about certain things
like for instance um uh
luke skywalker is the archetype of the
hero right so you go to see star wars
you watch a movie
with uh you know luke skywalker flying
his you know
his fighter spacecraft and with his
lightsaber and everything like that
you're seeing a movie an adventure movie
but underneath it all you are you are
seeing the archetype
of the of the hero right so
and we we know that we can tap into that
and i would argue that we can tap
into the archetype of the owl like i
talked to a lot of people who see owls
and they
almost no one says oh i saw an owl
people will come to you and say like
i saw this owl it might nothing at all
might have been on a fence and they said
it was so
powerful like it was so striking to see
an owl up close
so along with that
um well culturally they're just they're
just tied with like
spooky spookiness or
and that goes right into the bible
there's there's parts where owls are
mentioned in the bible and it sounds
just like if it was like a spooky movie
there they show up in places where they
are like a set piece when
within the bible they're talking about
like the wasteland the baron the desert
you know this uh these lonely spooky
places
they'll say there were owls there so
that's exactly right that has been
within our
psyche for forever so
but if there is a deeper meaning
now i'm going way out on a limb with
these ideas here but if there's a deeper
meaning within
the owl that we can tap it into
subconsciously
and they arrive at the moment of ufo
contact so here's this is totally what's
normal is
i get stories like this all the time
walking through the woods i looked up i
saw an owl the next thing i knew
a flying saucer passes right over me
that's very common
so the owl they're seeing a real owl and
it is showing up
in the context of uh of a
of a ufo contact or ufo sighting so
is it a punctuation mark is it like an
explanation is exclamation point within
the narrative the real of their reality
does that make sense like if
the owl is showing up for some
reason if only so the so the person
pays attention more that is so so you
ask like why owls the simplest thing i
could say why owls
is to pay attention it's like a symbol
to pay attention another thing i say
it's an alarm clock
it's like it's it's a ringing bell like
forcing you to pay attention forcing you
to wake up
so what what does that have to do with
if it's a real owl versus i mean how
could it not be a real owl
okay so so you so you were a little bit
ago you asked about the four foot tall
owls
right so here's this is there's two
avenues of
of this of the owl sighting one avenue
is a real owl
and what is very commonly reported and i
get this a lot
is here i'll tell a little story this
guy at a ufo conference uh
people in a group they sit in a circle
like a like an uh alcoholics anonymous
meeting
and they talk about like they talk about
like you know hello my name is joe and i
think i've been abducted by aliens it's
basically the vibe of it
yeah just a little bit at the bottom of
it great it's strong uh good
and uh so perfect
and then so um they
you know they tell their stories they
tell their experiences
and i was in this once and this was at a
ufo conference where there's a
big uh like people go to ufo conferences
and
people who have had the contact
experiences will show up at the
conference and then they will often have
a support group meeting at night it's
closed to uh reporters and things like
that
so there's a guy sitting off the corner
the whole time and he's kind of like
this the whole time
and he he he at the end of the meeting
he kind of raises his hand so listen i
have to ask people in the room
has anyone here ever had any odd
experiences with owls
and this guy like almost fell out of his
chair when everyone rose their hand
including me
and he was just like so he told a story
so this is the story that shows up a lot
he's driving down the road at night and
he's
he sees this big owl on the side of the
road it's like four foot tall
and he goes right up to it rolls his
window down he looks right at it's right
next to his driver's side window and he
looks at this big four foot tall owl
and he gets a really bad feeling and he
drives home
later he's a photographer later he goes
into the woods and you know that he
knows there's an owl's nest in the tree
so he's taking pictures of this owls
he's looking at the owls and he says
i don't think that was an owl i saw on
the side of the road
so he went through hypnotic regression
to try to figure out what he actually
saw
and he said that
really emerged in the hypnosis session
except that he has a memory
a vague memory of the owl wearing boots
okay so there's no nothing proof here
but what is what is commonly
reported is this tall four foot tall owl
and commonly reported
commonly reported what is that can you
give me numbers what is comments i wish
i knew
so so i don't know what percentage of
your stories are four foot tall owls
25 wow maybe 50
less than 50 more than 25 somewhere in
there
okay so uh
so here's another story so so the
implication is that the gray alien is
using some sort of
psychic impression to to
distort the observer's mind use
i'm this is so common in the literature
and so uh there's a um
and i've heard it many times you listen
to the hypnosis transcripts
or the hypnosis recordings where uh
someone will say like oh i saw four foot
all on the road and then the
hypnotherapist says describe the owl
well it's bald it's got big black eyes
it's skinny it's wearing a shiny
uniform it's got long fingers and i
don't think that's an owl
it's very commonly reported that at the
end of a ufo contact experience
the beings oftentimes the grey aliens
will kind of say
you will remember us as owls
now it's not just so this is in the in
the literature this is called a screen
memory
so there's a screen somehow that they
use either technology
or psychic means to distort what the
what the witness is seeing now it's not
just owls it's
it's um deer owls and deer are at the
top of the list
people see deer under odd circumstances
um
and then
then after that it's cats raccoons
squirrels
clowns is commonly reported jesus gets
reported every once in a while as far as
showing up as a screen memory so
so somehow they're are they are they
like how are they tapping into the mind
of the observer i cannot even begin to
imagine if it's technology or psychic
means
so here's another story that um that is
on the screen memory aspect there's a
woman i know i know her well
i trust her she was working at a girls
school for kids she was like 19 years
old
a summer camp and there was like
buildings
and she walked from one building to the
other and she had to kind of walk
through a trail so she wasn't like deep
in the woods or anything she was just
like between two buildings
and she could hear kids the girls
playing in the background and she turns
the corner and there's a gray alien
standing by the side of the trail
and she looks at the grey alien and it
looks at her and she hears this
like sort of echoing reverberating voice
in her head that says
and she watches this being turn into an
owl
like morph into an owl turn around and
run into the woods
so i got a couple stories like that
one with deer so i'm just saying
all i can do is report what what people
tell me right so
the but you hear you hear your 500th
story of someone seeing a four foot tall
owl on the side of the road while
driving at night
yeah it's going to drive you crazy right